- Balancing chemical
equations is one of those
concepts in chemistry that
often confuses people.
But I think we'll see that
if we work through this
carefully and methodically,
and we also appreciate
the art of balancing chemical equations,
that it's actually not too bad.
So first of all, what
is a chemical equation?
Well this is a chemical
equation right over here.
It's describing a reaction.
So if I take an atom of
aluminum and I add it
to a dioxygen molecule, so a molecule that
has two oxygens with it, under
the appropriate conditions
they will react to form aluminum oxide.
And the aluminum oxide molecule has
two aluminum atoms and three oxygen atoms.
And so you might say, "Okay, well what's
"the balancing business all about?
"I have a chemical reaction.
"What do I have to balance?"
Well if you look carefully,
you might notice that
you don't have the same number
of each atom on both sides.
For example, right over
here on the left-hand side,
how many aluminums do we have?
Well on the left-hand
side, we have one aluminum.
How many do we have on
the right-hand side?
Well on the right-hand
side, we have two aluminums.
And so aluminum just can't
appear out of thin air
by virtue of some magical reaction.
You have to have the same amount
of aluminums on both sides,
and the same thing is
true for the oxygens.
Over here on the left-hand
side, we have two oxygens.
They form one dioxygen molecule
that has two oxygen atoms.
And then over here in the
aluminum oxide molecule,
we have three.
We have three oxygen atoms.
So once again, we can't
just have miraculously
an oxygen atom appear out of nowhere.
So we have to balance the number
of aluminums on both sides,
this number and this
number should be the same,
and we have to balance
the number of oxygens,
this number and that
number should be the same.
So how do we do that?
Well one thing might be
to say, "Okay, if I've got
"two aluminums here and
I have one aluminum here,
"well why don't I just double the number
"of aluminums right over here?"
I could just write a two in front of it,
so now this has two aluminums,
so I no longer have one aluminum here.
I now have two aluminums,
and so it looks like
the aluminums are balanced,
and they are indeed balanced.
But still we have an
issue with the oxygens.
Over here I have two oxygens.
Over here I have three oxygens.
So one thing that you might say is,
"Okay, well how do I go from two to three?
"I could multiply by 1.5."
So I could multiply by 1.5,
and if I multiply 1.5 times two,
that's going to be three.
So now I have three
oxygen atoms on this side
and three oxygen atoms on this side.
But the convention is that we don't like
writing "1.5 molecules."
We don't like having this
notion of a half molecule,
which is kind of this bizarre notion.
We want whole number molecules.
So what can we do?
Well, you can imagine that
this makes it very similar
to what you did in algebra,
an algebraic equation.
We just can multiply both
sides by the same number
that gets rid of having this
fraction or this decimal here.
So if we multiplied both sides
by two, we're going to do that.
This is going to be a four,
this is going to be a three,
this is going to be a two right over here.
So let me do that.
Let me multiply both sides by two.
So instead of two aluminum atoms,
let me have four aluminum...
Actually, let me just write
the chemical equation first
in the form that it was before.
So I had aluminum plus dioxygen,
a molecule of two oxygens,
yielding in the reaction --
these are the reactants,
this is the product --
aluminum, aluminum, aluminum oxide.
So what I'm saying here
is to get rid of this 1.5,
to turn it into a whole number,
let's multiply all of these,
all of the number of molecules by two.
And here, there's implicitly a one...
Let me do this in a different color.
There is implicitly a one right over here.
So let's multiply all of these by two.
So two times two is...
Let me do that same color.
Two times two is four...
That's not the same color.
Two times two is four.
1.5 times two is three.
And then one times two,
one times two is two.
And now you can verify how many aluminums
do we have on each side?
Well I have four aluminum
atoms on the left-hand side,
and how many do I have
on the right-hand side?
I have four aluminum atoms.
How many oxygens do I have
on the left-hand side?
I have three molecules of dioxygen.
Each molecule has two oxygen atoms,
so I have six oxygens on the left,
and I have two times three oxygens
on the right, or I have six oxygens.
So my chemical equation is now balanced.